summer 2019 more than 38,000 fires raged
across the Amazon fires that were
man-made over the past 50 years almost
17% of the world's largest rainforest
has been cleared and globally
deforestation has almost doubled in just
five years since the start of human
civilization it's estimated that the
number of trees around the world has
fallen by almost half clearing forests
increases carbon dioxide levels but
planting them could store away some of
the carbon already in the atmosphere
everyone is looking for a silver bullet
to get our way out of this really
difficult problem of climate change
some people have latched on to tree
planting as a kind of panacea
the reality is tree planting is not
always good this woman runs safaris in
[Music]
England guests are not only here to see
wild animals there to see wild trees if
you could imagine when we were farming
back in the 1980s through the 90s this
would have been a field of one
particular crop as far as the eye can
see almost 20 years ago
Izabella tree yes that is her real name
founded 1,400 hectares of Sussex
farmland back to nature by doing well
nothing she thinks this is the best way
to use the land to help tackle climate
change
Wilding is a hands-off approach it's
become a sort of environment that is a
nursery for open grown freely
regenerating trees within 20 years we
have doubled our carbon sequestered in
the soil
we've got the scrub we've got the
grasses we've got the trees all that
will be contributing to this carbon sink
to stabilize the climate global carbon
emissions need to drop to Net Zero by
2050 and of course not all sectors are
going to get down to zero emissions by
2050 Simon Lewis is a professor of
global change science we need to take
some carbon out of the atmosphere and
one of the cheapest easiest ways is to
plant trees around half the dry weight
of a tree is carbon as trees grow they
take carbon out of the atmosphere and
store it in their trunks leaves and
roots which help slow the rate of
climate change and has never been more
global ambition to plant trees in 2014
51 countries pledged to plant over 3.5
million square kilometres of forest by
2030 an area slightly larger than India
Gopa has made its mark in the record
books by planting over 350 million trees
in a single day the 2030 target looks
likely to be met but there's a catch
when you dig down into the numbers of
these forests almost half the area
pledged so far by countries is actually
for monoculture plantations and that
means a single species planted over
thousands and thousands of hectares
monoculture tree plantations like
eucalyptus grow quickly but the trees
are harvested every 10 or so years
releasing much of the carbon stored in
the tree back into the atmosphere which
means that according to some studies
they'll store only around one 40th of
the carbon natural forests do over the
long term so it's made into short-term
products like paper and then when that
paper is used and then discarded
decomposes and that carbon goes back
into the atmosphere
Simon analyzed pledges from 43 countries
in the tropics and subtropics these big
announcements are not going to deliver
on the carbon capture that we're
expecting if they move natural forests
would sequester 42 billion tons of
carbon this century in fact those
pledges to plant millions of trees
actually promise to store 26 billion
tons less carbon than they could
[Music]
sometimes the motives for planting
forests are less green than they might
appear by 2020 Island ought to have cut
greenhouse gas emissions by 20% below
2005 levels but at current rates it will
have reduced them by only 5%
planting forests might help island avoid
massive penalties for missing EU targets
because the potential carbon these
forests could store in the future can be
counted as a carbon credit today in the
1920s Ireland had the lowest forest
cover in Europe at around 1% that's now
risen to 11% and the government has set
a target to cover 18% of the land with
forest by 2046 an island they're rapidly
increasing the amount of forest cover
but it's overwhelmingly going towards
monoculture plantations of conifers and
now local community groups are
protesting against these monoculture
tree plantations they say they're doing
more harm than good because these
monoculture plantations are about
getting the maximum yield as fast as
possible they often apply fertilisers
which contribute to greenhouse gas
nitrous oxide conifer plantations are
very densely stocked so come out almost
all the light are very poor for
biodiversity and can really affect
people living nearby tree planting
programs invariably have an impact on
the people living nearby in East Africa
one project is demonstrating what can be
achieved when there's genuine buy-in
from the local communities Green
Ethiopia is a mixed tree planting
charity we plant seedlings in rural
areas of India that is heavily affected
by degradation due to deforestation
the land is communally owned and
cooperatives of local women receive
benefits for planting trees which are
protected from being harvested
empowering the local community tree
planting contribute a lot for the
sustainability of forestation activities
because it creates the sense of
ownership the local communities strongly
participate on planting managing and
conserving their sites here
conserving is just as important as
planting green Ethiopia assesses whether
the condition of the land is good enough
to regenerate by itself when it is on
about a third of the area the charity
runs they leave it alone just like
Isabella tree back in England perhaps
the right way to think about tree
planting is just leave the land and it
can do it spontaneously itself there's
no need for interventions by humans in
most cases but this approach brings its
own challenges the problem with this
kind of natural regeneration is it's
very difficult to get funding the
funding is all driven by targets the
numbers gain in a regenerated landscape
like this we can't have any idea of how
many Oaks they'll be or how many
crabapples will come monoculture
plantations are often preferred because
they make money so some experts are
looking to a future where carbon
payments could create financial
incentives for natural forests if carbon
becomes much more important as a
commodity then perhaps though these
natural forests will become more
profitable than
as a real opportunity here to shift the
incentives towards getting benefits for
the climate and benefits for local
people and benefits for local wildlife
ultimately though the trouble with trees
tackling climate change is space there's
just not enough land in the world to
plant enough trees to offset all the
carbon emissions from fossil fuels we
could say let's restore forests on every
single piece of land that used to have
forests on from before agriculture and
if we did that it would be about 200
billion tons of carbon now that sounds a
lot but to put it in context that's
about 20 years worth of emissions at
present breaks tree planting might be
looked at as a savior but it's not it's
not an excuse not to cut fossil fuel
emissions I'm Sarah the director of this
film if you want to learn more about
this topic you can watch the story
behind trees and climate change at the
link opposite at the other link you can
find some articles we use for research
and some other exclusive materials
thanks for watching
you